my apartment building that I'm that I'm
being um I'm leaving because I am uh
done with it
and I'm going elsewhere uh
has sent me this weird thing it's like
uh a a form where I have to vacate my
lease I've never heard of this and no
one else has ever heard of it either
you're just supposed to leave right but
they've put like this thing in the form
now get this up this is something that
the people at my apartment building 10
000 Santa Monica in Los Angeles which by
the way is a dump yeah I'm gonna say it
right now it's for rich people whose
lives did not work out it's for divorced
ads it's for Russian Instagram thoughts
it's for young Saudi royalty shout out
to the whole MBS and the whole fam
um it's you know all of that and it's
tick-tockers tick-tocking away but what
it is is it it is absolute it is no
class it has no distinction it is an
undignified home for anyone with any
money it is undignified if you have any
type of pedigree if you've even been
near a school if you've even sat in the
same room with a book it's not for you
it is disgusting new money Zoo full of
junkies the police roamed the Halls
keeping the junkies in their cells the
people beat the [ __ ] out of each other
in their apartments and the cops have to
come and pick up all of the and then
sort the pills on the floor and give
each group each party the right amount
of medication to settle them down the
amenities the gym the pool they usually
don't work there always is that the
other thing
our friend Ida is there now and she's
impressed by it but uh she's impressed
by uh anything so
the reality is it's just not a nice
place now I didn't know that when I
moved in people told me that they said
it as a dark energy Steve Bing jumped
out of one of the windows and splattered
himself all over the valet now this is
these are all facts so I'm not saying
anything bad about the building if you'd
like to live in a building with junkies
where some of them occasionally jump out
of the windows and splatter themselves
all over the valet it is a good option
it is not a bad option if you like
excitement if you like drug addicts and
uh people that are famous for no reason
that have no Talent walking around
trying to figure out the coffee machine
because they're too high it's not a bad
idea
now I didn't like that so I'm moving on
now these people these people at the
building tried to get me can you pull
this up Francis yeah pull this up
because uh how dare they read this Ben
if you can
non-disparagement clause and this is
never heard of this ever a not and I'm
not disparaging it I'm being honest
solely simply honest
and you had to sign this because you're
moving out October and they tricked me
they like threw this in there
tenant agrees that they will not
disparage 10 000 or any of their
officers directors or employees some of
the people that work there are nice yeah
I like a lot I like a lot of the people
that work there I'm talking exclusively
about the ones who do not steal your
food
for purposes of this paragraph disparage
shall mean any negative statement
whether written or oral about ten
thousand or its officers attract
tourists or employees uh you agree and
acknowledge that this non-disparagement
provision is a material term of this
notice the absence of which would have
resulted in the parties refusing to
enter into this notice I don't know what
that means what I'll tell you is this is
a dump and I'll never stop saying it's a
dump I will say it everywhere on every
platform I actually wasn't going to say
it until I got that now I'm going to say
it everywhere I'm going to start every
media appearance I have talking about
what a dump it is and you didn't sign
that right I think I might have
no but because it's in East
no it's an e-signature it's an
e-signature that you can't take off I
tried to take it off
you can't delete it no you can't you
can't delete it but I responded I'm not
signing this it's America this is my
constitutional rights I'm a
trans-indigenous you dumb [ __ ] I
respond to that but I do think my
signatures on it but I did because you
can't delete the e-signature but I
emailed her immediately take it back
going I'm not this isn't for me okay I
said that well and I called lawyers well
what do you mean well they can these
e-signatures they sneak this [ __ ] in
but I emailed her I said I'm trans
indigenous and I'm not signing this it's
against my constitutional right you dumb
[ __ ]
that's what I said and that's what I
believe
you did actually write that I I saw that
I liked the building
I mean
my signature's on the line but I tried
to act I tried to delete it like nine
times
they can't get me I got too many [ __ ]
lawyers they don't want to get into a
high profile battle with me I will do a
battle with them we'll get in a high
profile legal bad they don't want it
they don't want that smoke as the as the
the drill RAP Community would say
they'll just back off you think well
yeah
I don't even lit I'm leaving yeah I'm
not even supposed to be there
I'm done
my friend Ida is there killer if you
want to really hurt me go like if they
want to if they want to just throw her
out of the just Bing her
Binger
Binger right over to the balcony
um but that's the I would like to say
one positive thing about you as a
resident there if they're listening to
this you were one of the few people
paying rent I just do want to put that
out there because everyone else is on
drugs right
yeah
right the finishes suck as a luxury
building that's not good they need to
they need to turn flip a condo they need
to go in there with new finishes they're
getting a lot of money right now I
understand it because people you know
get divorced and they have to bring
their sad [ __ ] Rich ass family just
to take the elevator up and go remember
when we were a family but Dad Dad just
you know Christmas wasn't enough for Dad
or Chris I mean Hanukkah but whatever it
wasn't enough for dad dad needed to go
see the [ __ ] and now we live in this
apartment and isn't the view nice oh
look at the view it's so nice remember
the the old view used to have the one of
your mother
and the family well we don't have that
view anymore but look you can see the
ocean kind of through the smog a little
not really
I wish everyone well it's a good
building and if you if you need it it's
good for you
moving on
moving on